foreign
Dorothy is in DC hey Dorothy
hi George and Ken I'm calling in today
because I'm working on baby steps four
and six simultaneously and I wanted to
know whether or not I should buy a new
car with the extended warranty for about
fifty four thousand dollars whoa
okay this is a party what do you make
Dorothy
I currently make
um about uh 70 or 80 000 a year why did
you laugh
because I wrote that information down
but I don't have it in front of me right
now oh okay okay so what's the deal with
this new car
why do we need to get a fifty four
thousand dollar code um during a car
accident back in April I got a
settlement for it for about eight
thousand dollars and then I plan to put
ten thousand out ten thousand down on
the new car adding the tax refund that
I'm expecting to get of about two
thousand dollars so how much money do
you have in the bank
I have about seventy seven thousand
dollars seventy seven thousand yes sir
whoa what is that from
that is from me saving for my emergency
fund so if I take out the 36 from the
emergency fund it leaves 41 000 the rest
of the money is for me Airbnb in my
primary home while I'm away on Military
orders okay so you've got an Airbnb
you've got your emergency fund in there
and that's that's money that's set aside
for those things but for the car you
don't have money to buy this car right
now
I don't have the full amount of money to
buy the car but I also didn't want to
empty my bank account completely when
I'm trying to build more with the new
LLC I just started for real estate
investment here's what I'm seeing
Dorothy you are so smart in fact you are
too smart to go into car loan debt for a
car that you can't afford that's over
half your income
so I'm confused where this is coming
from you have no debt right now right
no I don't but I didn't want to prevent
myself from building additional wealth
through the new business that I just
started but can I tell you that buying a
car is the number one way to kill your
wealth
to go into debt with interest on a
depreciating asset
okay so the question is how much money
do we have and then we go all right how
much car can we get for that amount of
money that's how I would be looking at
this thing
so the problem is when I was comparing
new cars to used cars
um they were just about not that much
not that much cheaper for one and two I
need a reliable car in order to get back
and forth to work okay so let's look at
the real numbers so I thought I heard
you say tell me if I'm wrong that you
had uh eight thousand dollars from the
uh settlement and you you had 10 that
you were gonna put did I hear eighteen
thousand is how I got there is that what
I heard no you heard eight plus two from
the tax refund so that is how I get to
the 10. oh you have 10 to put towards
okay good that's why I asked okay so
um you think that you can't have a
reliable car that you would purchase for
ten thousand dollars is that fair
yes all right so what is the number that
makes it reliable in your mind
how much more well because you're not
looking for when I was looking at other
Honda Accords to replace the one that
was totaled it was about thirty thousand
dollars for one year for what year of a
Honda Accord
uh 2019. exactly I'm sitting next to a
Honda Accord specialist in George
Campbell who drove I drove a Civic I
apologize a Civic but a hospital but I
am one of my dream cars Dorothy was a
Honda Accord all right but my point is
is that if she's looking at a
2010-2011 2012. uh all of a sudden
Dorothy the price of those Hondas that
will run forever if you take care of
them and you have enough money to be
able to take care of basic repairs
that's why we have that emergency fund
I'm I just you've gotten your mind that
the only thing that's reliable is 30 to
54 000 and that's just simply not the
case
so imagine then if I'm right and you may
not think I am but imagine if I am now
you have zero dollars in car payment
versus whatever your car payment is
going to be with that fifty four
thousand dollar car
it would potentially be 660 a month okay
at 4.9 for 72. that's crazy that hurts
my heart to see Dorothy's income get
sent to
Honda lender because she wanted a nice
car
this time but yes I understand your
point okay but it's over eight thousand
dollars of a pay cut for you if you buy
this car
yes okay then that's what we're trying
to plead with you on
we're not anti-people buying cars just
for the sake of buying a car it's that
it doesn't make Financial sense for you
and please do not get the extended
warranty those are a giant rip-off and
the mathematics behind it shows that
they are almost never worth it and so if
you want peace of mind you have an
emergency fund for that and so if there
is a repair you're going to be able to
cover it and if you get a reliable
vehicle like the Honda Accord for
example and you get a pre-purchase
inspection on it you can find a very
reasonable used Honda and while Honda
and Toyota they're going to hold their
value pretty well because they're great
cars everyone knows that and so you may
pay you know 10 grand for a I don't know
a 2010 Accord and you might go all right
that's reasonable I had an 09 Civic I
paid six grand for it that thing will
probably Outlast me if I'm gonna be
honest I will it'll probably happen for
me with buying a 2010 Honda Accord is
that that literally was the car that I
had and it only had 129 129 000 miles on
it and now it's gone
because of a car wreck so the 54 000 car
has got the same chance of getting
totaled as well
so me doing the comparison of what the
other people did or didn't do as far as
maintenance keeps Milling around in my
head well they have reports that show
you exactly what maintenance was done
and if you get the right car from the
right place they're going to have all of
that for you and they'll show you
exactly when the oil changes were done
when the brakes were replaced and all of
that stuff
and I'm telling you with a pre-purchase
inspection it takes all the worry out
they're gonna go look at the thing and
go hey here's the issues here's what it
doesn't have and here's what it would
cost to fix up or it's in great
condition go buy the car and that'll
cost you 100 to 150 bucks to get that
done at your local mechanic Dorothy we
get calls all the time on the show from
people who bought a car same price same
range and then something goes wrong in
their world their business or whatever
and all of a sudden they realize they're
upside down this car because your car is
going to depreciate in a year from now
you could be upside down in this car
and then you're really in trouble
okay you see the difference between
paying cash or something versus you you
finance it and then it is depreciating
on you and then you then you're stuck
you're not stuck right now I hate that
your car got totaled but you got an
eight thousand dollar check for it and
you can put some cash on top of what you
got and you can get a reliable car
you're trying to make a business go
you're trying to go all in last thing an
entrepreneur needs is a car payment it's
just going to be weighing you down
as you get this LLC off the ground and
we want to see you win that's it I want
Dorothy to be driving like no one else
but right now we got to drive like no
one else you know what I mean
okay so I guess my my follow-up question
and final idea is that I'm basically
looking at the comparison of using other
people's money or money or getting into
debt for the business versus getting
into debt for the car and what I'm
hearing you say is getting into the debt
for the car isn't worth it because of
the depreciation getting into debt for
anything is worth it and if you're going
to use it for the business for sure not
I want you to run your business debt
free and we show you how to do that in
the book entree leadership and I'm going
to send it to you to give you some Hope
on the business side and on the car side
go to AutoTrader or true cars and start
looking and sort by your actual budget
which right now is ten thousand dollars
and get what you can afford right now
and you can always upgrade down the line
down the line until you're driving like
no one else so hang the line we'll send
you a Dave's best-selling book entree
leadership to show you that it's
possible to run a business completely
debt free thanks for the call